Pacific Rim 2 has been off and on again
more times than Ross and Rachel over the
past few months while Guillermo del Toro
director of the original 2014 sci-fi
blockbuster has always insisted that the
project was moving ahead various press
stories and its disappear and some
release head Jules suggested otherwise
however it has now been reported that
the movie has a new director attached to
it I'm Lucy and welcome to this drift
compatible GameSpot news update
according to Deadline Steven s tonight
has been hired by producers at legendary
pictures to helm Pacific Rim - tonight
is best known for his work on Netflix's
hit Marvel show daredevil where he
served as executive producer and head
writer for its first season he also
created the series Spartacus and has
worked on such hit shows as Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and Smallville del Toro
will remain on board as producer and
yesterday tweeted his approval of the
news met with tonight and we are all so
happy with our choice to take Pacific
Rim - to where we know it can go so
would you watch your Pacific Rim sequel
let me know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
games games for more kaiju calamities
keep it GameSpot